[Música]
es el momento de hablar de ciencia y
tecnología en france24 soy valentina
torre sánchez y en esta ocasión los
acompaño desde casa a causa de la
pandemia de kobe 19 ya hace varias
semanas científicos chinos indicaron que
se preparaban desde ese momento para una
posible futura pandemia ahora son varios
los países que están adelantando
estudios y trabajando en conjunto para
estar preparados ante nuevas amenazas
sanitarias a este laboratorio de londres
asisten voluntarios sanos que son
expuestos a diversos patógenos para
poder aprender más sobre enfermedades y
probar fármacos uno de los virus que
estudian es justamente el cubil 19 pero
los investigadores están de acuerdo en
que es cuestión de tiempo que otro virus
ponga a los seres humanos en riesgo
y habrá futuras pandemias
es decir claramente todo ha cambiado y
este ha sido un punto de giro en
términos de como veremos las pandemias
en el futuro y cómo vamos a necesitar
estar mucho más preparados y más specter
pl
antes del cob y ya se conocían al menos
6 coronavirus que afectaban a los seres
humanos los últimos dos fueron a izar su
síndrome respiratorio agudo grave
identificado en 2003 y ellmers o
síndrome respiratorio de oriente medio
en 2012 ambos virus afectaron a una
veintena de países y produjeron síntomas
graves y fallecimientos los científicos
aseguran que la forma en la que se
presentaron esos coronavirus hizo que
los sistemas sanitarios no dimensionaron
la magnitud y la dificultad de la
pandemia que venía en camino con el
joven 19 we go law dick wolf usen sus
security y todos fuimos arrastrados a un
falso sentido de seguridad porque el
sars y el merz se esparcían de personas
con síntomas y lo que no esperábamos era
que un nuevo corolla virus surgiera y
pudiese ser transmitido por personas que
ni siquiera sabían que lo tenían
systematics red así que fue el contagio
a sintomático el comportamiento
diferente lo que nos tomó desprevenidos
cuando los expertos hacen un énfasis
especial al decir que cada vez se corren
más riesgos de contraer virus que antes
sólo estaban en el reino animal esto
porque los seres humanos hemos invadido
los hábitats donde previamente vivían
animales salvajes esa transmisión se ve
agravada por la cría intensiva de
animales y por la convivencia con ellos
todos esos factores favorecen la
mutación de los virus a los seres
humanos ouija nos hemos tenido esta
creciente avalancha de zoonosis saben
transferir patógenos del reino animal a
los humanos así fue con el vih el ébola
el sars ellmers o el cob y 19no
y parece que cada vez ocurre con más
frecuencia y hay más razones para ello
que tienen que ver con nuestra
urbanización nuestra invasión del
entorno natural y con tener un mayor
contacto con el reino animal contra el
booking cada año la organización mundial
de la salud elabora una lista de los
patógenos con más probabilidades de
convertirse en una amenaza antes de 2020
y la fiebre hemorrágica de crimea-congo
y la gula encabezada en esa lista el año
pasado lo hizo el joven 19
continuamos hablando de este virus pero
ahora de las estrategias que están
implementando algunas aerolíneas para
proteger a su tripulación y generar
confianza en los viajeros en el
aeropuerto de heathrow en londres
virgin atlantic está usando una
aplicación creada por una firma de
tecnología biométrica que ahora integra
los resultados de las pruebas rápidas de
ccoo y 19 de los pilotos y demás
personal de cabina antes de cada vuelo
se trata de confianza los viajes
internacionales están en una fracción de
lo que eran antes de marzo del año
pasado y realmente para abrir fronteras
y transportar gente en las dimensiones
del año pasado necesitamos crear
confianza entre los países para que las
personas puedan viajar más libremente
tanto quienes impulsan estas
aplicaciones de tecnología biométrica
como el personal de la compañía aérea
defienden que los llamados pasaportes
kobe o certificados sanitarios digitales
de los viajeros serán clave en los
próximos meses para poder reactivar el
turismo en todo el mundo
esta primavera y este verano para poner
en marcha la aviación los pasos
sanitarios serán absolutamente
esenciales de lo contrario verificar las
documentaciones será terriblemente
difícil verificar todo el papeleo y
todos los diferentes requisitos en los
distintos destinos eso será realmente
realmente difícil tanto para nuestros
equipos como para nuestros clientes y
para finalizar vamos a conocer la
historia de vila la multi un inventor
marroquí de 12 años que creó lo que él
llama la mascarilla del futuro es un
artefacto diseñado para prevenir el
esparcimiento de infecciones que se
transmitan al toser o estornudar pues la
máscara se ubica automáticamente sobre
la boca y la nariz y mehmet ekici a la
llama máscara del futuro porque es una
mascarilla inteligente que está
programada contra toser y estornudar
la inventé porque me di cuenta que las
personas no cubren su boca en sus
oficinas o en otros lugares
si están contagiados con un virus
esparcirán la infección en ese lugar y
cualquiera puede contraer lo a multi
cano el primer premio en la categoría a
futuros ingenieros en un concurso
internacional de robótica en el que
participaron cientos de personas de 21
países le tomó dos meses crear su
invento
así llegamos al final de este espacio
pero recuerden que pueden repetir este y
otros programas en nuestra web 224 punto
com
avda
más